est ce que vous vous rendez compte que
chaque année on rejette 6,5 milliards de
déchets plastiques 5.5 milliards de
kilos de déchets plastiques dans les
mers durant la période de ma
présentation 171,1 millions de tonnes
d'eau polluée seront rejetés dans les
océans et pendant cette même
présentation 135 personnes mourront due
à une eau de mauvaise qualité
est ce que ça ne vous choque pas mais
moi en tant biologiste ça me révolte
ça me révolte car je pense qu'on ne peut
pas laisser faire ça y est comment en
on peut encore voir des comportements
comme jeter son papier par la fenêtre
d'une voiture
comment on peut être aussi un différent
par rapport à l'impact qu'on a sur notre
environnement
eh bien vous savez parfois on se
retrouve avec des amis dans un bar et on
discute comme cette chose qui nous
révolte qui nous passionne et pour
lesquelles on sent impuissant eh bien
ces jours de discussions là qui a mené
cinq amis à parcourir le fleuve saint
laurent au canada en kayak mais 400 km à
la force des bras dans un but de
sensibilisation à l'environnement
je crois que ce qui était le plus fou
dans l'histoire c'est que on n'avait
jamais fait de kayak avant s'est pas
fait
et on avait déjà annoncé notre aventure
aux médias et personnellement j'ai été
deux fois sur la laisse faire la
descente de la lesse mais la laisse ça
n'a rien à voir avec le fleuve
saint-laurent le fleuve saint laurent
c'est grand c'est colossal c'est tim en
sont les eaux s'étendent à perte de vue
et et des voiles de st laurent non
seulement est immense mais il dit varier
d'un point de vue écologique d'où son
intérêt son importance et juste pour
vous le prouver
c'est l'endroit où viennent se nourrir
les baleines durant l'été donc c'est aux
sons sont vraiment riche et pas
seulement pour les animaux qui y vivent
mais également pour les hommes les
hommes en tirer un grand profit d'un
point de vue économique mais aussi c'est
un fleuve qui est ancré dans l'histoire
est toute la tradition des loisirs et la
culture de tous ces riverains
alors vous allez me dire mais pourquoi
s'attaquer au fleuve saint-laurent
pourquoi le canada parce que j'ai pas
l'accent québécois quand je parle bien à
ce moment là j'y vivais je travaillais
comme plongeur scientifique dans le
fleuve
chaque jour je plongeais et avec mes
compatriotes et et tous mes camarades
d'expédition vanier on était chargé de
l'interprétation de de tout ce qui se
passe d'un point de vue écologique de la
biologie du fleuve de du fond marin
également et on parlait pas que la
biologie l'écologie on parle également
de de la navigation qui peut être très
difficile à cause des eaux font des
conditions climatiques très changeante
et aussi de l'âne est aussi la
construction des phares un peu toute
l'histoire
bref on était ancré dans dans toute
cette vie autour du fleuve et on se
retrouver mais parfois le soir avec les
collègues et ont discuté comme ça des
anecdotes de la journée et ce soir là
c'était vraiment à propos des enjeux
environnementaux et toutes les anecdotes
tournait autour de comment les gens
arrivent à être aussi indifférent aussi
blasé de
du monde qui nous entoure et moi mon
anecdote ce jour là c'était une dame qui
est arrivé dans le centre
elle a fait très brièvement le petit
tour du musée qu'on avait et après les
venues me voir et me dit qu est-ce qui a
d'autres à faire ici qu'est-ce qui a
d'autres à voir et moi je suis dit d'un
ton enthousiaste vous savez où on a la
chance aujourd'hui d'avoir une baleine
bleue qui passe à dix mètres au large de
là où on se trouvait imaginez la baleine
bleue c'est quand même l'animal le plus
gros n'ayant jamais vécu sur terre plus
gros que tous les dinosaures est juste
un peu plus loin un groupe de béluga les
bélougas sont des baleines blanches qui
sont originaires du visible généralement
dans les eaux arctiques et on en voyait
juste un groupe derrière la baleine
bleue un peu plus loin donc c'est quand
même pas une situation qu'on observe
tous les jours imaginez ma tête quand
cette dame m'a regardé d'un air blasé à
une baleine
j'en ai vu une ce matin et puis elle
retourne au parking pris sa voiture et
les parties c'est dans quelle distance
on prend par rapport aux mots quand on
coche les observations comme ça et puis
on continue notre voyage comment on peut
pas prendre cinq minutes pour prendre
justement un peu de plaisir et regarder
quelque chose qui se passe devant nous
et là on discute et on s'est dit mal et
qu il faut faire quelque chose il faut
vraiment bouger les gens mais comment on
va faire faut attirer l'attention sur
sur notre but notre cause et c'est comme
ça qu'on a eu l'idée de se lancer un
défi
selon c'est un défi mais ça a été
parcourir le fleuve le fleuve en kayak
alors il a très vite fallu mettre tout
en place comme on l'avait annoncé dans
les médias
eh bien on a dû rechercher ce soit du
matériel des financements pour faire
cette expédition est également créé un
plan de communication très solide paire
c'était vraiment objectif premier dans
ce double objectif et donc par là on a
vraiment essayé de partager un maximum
via des photos et tout ça mais beaucoup
de projets parallèles dont un j'aimerais
bien discuter
un petit peu avec vous c'est comme l'a
très bien dit saint-exupéry on ne mérite
pas de la terre de nos ancêtres
mais on l'empruntons à nos enfants c'est
pour ça qu'on avale voulu inclure des
jeunes dans notre expédition pendant
kayak mais ils nous ont suivi tout le
monde via des vidéoconférences et on les
a intégrés vraiment dès le début du
projet dans toute la participation et
ont trouvé vraiment important qu'il
sente impliqué dans notre réussite comme
ça serait le réussit à eux aussi et
comment on a fait un exemple d'activité
qu'on a réalisé avant l'expédition
c'est en général ne faisait neuf jeunes
sur dix vont dire c'est pas bien de
polluer c'est pas bien de jeter son
papier à terre mais comment est-ce
qu'ils l'intègrent dans le monde
complexe dans lequel on vit comment
est-ce qu'il peut savoir que l'impact
qu'il en jetant son papier à terre mais
c'est très simple on a pris les enfants
et on est allés voir leur a dit ben
voila tu jettes ton papier à terre et on
était là où tout les cas l'année
canalisations du village se rejettent et
c'était au bord du fleuve justement on
va sur la plage et et bien le regard des
jeunes vraiment changé ils sont rendus
compte de l'impact qu'on avait
directement car les autres canalisation
dans cet endroit bay sont rejetés via
juste un seul filtre et c'est une grille
avec des barreaux de 10 cm de long à peu
près donc on voyait sur la plage mais
des tampons usagers des morceaux de
plastique un peu dit
des traces d'hydrocarbure et ça a été
d'autant plus choquant que généralement
sur cette plage on voit des pêcheurs de
crevettes donc là les jeunes ce fait
mais c'est fou ça comment on peut faire
pour changer les choses
et là il ya une toute une réflexion qui
mise en place ben oui on peut par des
gestes simples de la vie tous les jours
on peut avoir un impact positif sur
notre environnement
donc on a été avec eux essayez de
rédiger de comprendre les étiquettes sur
les produits d'entretien ménager par
exemple et on a fait avec du savon
écologique savons pâte dentifrice qu'on
a utilisées durant toute notre
expédition donc ainsi il était vraiment
impliqué dans dans tout notre périple
donc bon donc on a dû commencer à
pagayer après tous ces préparatifs
et pagayer je vous dis qu'on a vraiment
pas gagné beaucoup avec une moyenne de
43 km par jour
on a été projeté au coeur d'un immense
bassin hydrographique on est parti de
l'extrémité des grands lacs pour passer
dans les zones les plus peuplées du
québec est finalement arrivé dans le
plus grand estuaire du monde 700 3000
coups de pagaie par personne on a
calculé
alors ça n'a pas été facile tous les
jours
vous pouvez me croire et dès le début
dès les premiers jours on a eu nos
premiers obstacles en fait entre
kingston et montréal ils ont construit
des grands barrages et des grosses
écluses pour faire passer les gros
paquebots bien entendu mais en kayak on
peut pas passer là dedans
donc il a fallu porter porté sur parfois
des kilomètres aller retour les kayaks
d'abord puis tout le matériel
donc c'était assez pénible et
s'accoupler avec les conditions météo
changeantes la pluie le vent bien on
allait assez lentement au début
25 km alors qu'on avait estimé 35 pour
arriver à temps à gaspé donc là on
commençait à douter mais avec notre
optimisme on a pu profiter de chaque
situation et on s'est vraiment améliorée
on a même pu prendre du plaisir dans les
conditions parfois un peu plus
rock'n'roll mais je veux dire que ce qui
nous a fait vraiment tenir et qui nous a
gardés motiver tout le long de ce
périple
mais c'est le soutien des gens en fait
on recevait général assez souvent des
messages via les réseaux sociaux
et ça s'est ressenti surtout à la moitié
de l'expédition
on dormait dans notre campement pas loin
d'un village et on s'est fait cambrioler
7 7000 hommes
imaginez imaginez vous vous levez le
matin il ya plus de pagaie plus de veste
de sécurité plus de matériel imperméable
et ni matériel électronique appareil
photo chargeurs solaires tout avait
disparu comme on le dit on était un peu
mal barré pour continuer sans pagaie
donc
là on était vraiment témoin d'un
mouvement de solidarité incroyable
vraiment tout s'est mis en branle les
médias les sponsors les magasins les
centres de kayak
si bien que moins de 24 heures plus tard
pour porter sur le fleuve avec du
matériel offert ou en prêt donc on était
parti d'une situation d'une rêverie
autour d'un verre dans un bar et on se
retrouvait là en plein milieu d'un grand
fleuve où on avait race rassembler une
communauté entière autour d'un intérêt
commun la protection de l'environnement
et là c'était quand même un sentiment
fort on s'est dit notre expédition en
vaut la peine
les gens les gens sont pour qu'on
termine donc ça nous a vraiment motivé
avancé alors ce soutien bon là également
ressenti en rencontrant des gens tout le
monde du voyage et des gens sont venus à
notre rencontre ont pris leurs vacances
exprès pour pour nous voir et et je me
souviens d'une personne qu'on a
rencontrés on était logés sur la plage
de rire son jardin et qui comprenait pas
pourquoi ont sauté dans l'eau tous les
jours parce qu'il y avait une canicule à
ce moment l'homme juste pour se
rafraîchir on a eu un petit peu puis
remonter dans le kayak en avant c'est et
disais mais enfin vous êtes fous hollow
aller polluer c'est dégueulasse vous
allez avoir des problèmes de peau il ya
des champignons qu'ils vont vous pousser
sur la pauvre imaginer sa tête quand lui
a dit que l'eau qu'ils buvaient tous les
jours qui sortait de son robinet belle
provenait du fleuve 15 20 kilomètres
plus tôt vous vous rendez compte de la
situation dans nos pays soi-disant
développés on prend l'eau potable comme
un droit tellement acquis qu'on se fout
de savoir d'où elle provient en fait on
pour couronner le tout alors qu'il ya
des millions de personnes qui meurent
chaque années dues à ce manque d'accès à
l'eau potable mais nous tous les jours
on chie dans l'eau potable
c'est quand même une situation qui fait
réfléchir alors ces rencontres bien
elles ont été avec les hommes et avec
tous les habitants du fleuve on a quand
même fait des rencontres exceptionnelles
avec la faune qui entourait ce
magnifique plan d'eau et on a pu
découvrir des paysages également
magnifique
des photos vraiment exceptionnel on en a
beaucoup beaucoup et est bien sûr cette
présence récurrente de l'homme partout
où on allait on voyait toujours des
déchets par ci par là
on s'était donné pour mission de de
ramasser les déchets qu'on ce qu'on
pouvait prendre sur nos kayaks
il ya quand même des gros bras mais ont
tous ces déchets qu'on a collecté durant
notre expédition les a ramenées à un
artiste rock lanthier il est spécialisé
dans tout ce qui est récupération de
vieux matériaux dont tous ceux dont on a
plus usage et il fait des oeuvres à
partir de ça pour essayer de donner une
deuxième vie à tous ces matériaux et
vous m'envoyer une photo récemment d'une
oeuvre qu'il avait terminée
c'est peut-être un peu naïf cet homme
s'appelle bon appétit mais c'est quand
même fort de sens car ces océans ces
mères qui nous ont nourris pendant des
milliers d'années
qu'est ce qu'elles ont à nous offrir
pour le futur alors cette expédition
nous a fait réaliser que la terre est
riche et elle regorge de trésors cachés
on n'a peut-être pas changer le cours
des choses on n'a pas arrêté la
déforestation on n'a pas sauver l'ours
polaire de la fonte des glaces mais si
on a pu changer l'une ou l'autre
mentalité par-ci par-là changer un
comportement c'est déjà une mission
réussie
et si pour changer milo de comportement
mille autre mentalité je dois demain à
traverser un désert pour le prouver je
le ferai sans hésiter car pour moi
chaque petit geste compte chacun à notre
niveau on est capable de changer les
choses alors j'espère que à partir de
demain
la prochaine fois que vous irez dans
l'eau potable vous penserez à moi
et si jamais vous retrouver avec des
amis à rêver de projet un peu fou mais
lâchez vous n'hésitez pas un instant car
ça risque d'être un des plus beaux
voyages de votre vie merci